chaque année estelle marie à une
organisation précise pour les
fournitures scolaires habitante des
mureaux et maman de quatre enfants elle
mixe les achats entre l'épicerie sociale
isa et les supermarchés avec une fille
au collège et trois en écoles primaires
et maternelles
les achats sont forcément conséquent
tous les ans je viens ici parce que il
ya beaucoup davantage il ya des choses
qui sont moins chers qu'en magasin les
stylos ils sont à 20 centimes et un
stylo en général faut compter au moins
un euro même en magasin l'année dernière
mais beaucoup de style aux quatre
couleurs ici c'est 4 5 euros en magasin
ici c'était un euro donc c'est plus
avantageux là je peux me permettre de
leur faire plus une rentrée scolaire
entière parce que sinon pour acheter une
tenue pour la rentrée et après on mois
pictures remplir le
l'armoire alors que là je peux remplir
l'armoire et faire les fournitures
accompagner et aider les personnes en
difficulté la vocation de l'épicerie
sociale de l'association insertion
solidarité autonomie des mureaux cette
action sur les fournitures scolaires et
existe depuis 2016 une collaboration
avec don solidaire basée à saint germain
en laye une entité spécialisée dans les
dons non alimentaires avec notamment les
fournitures scolaires autour d'un réseau
d'une vingtaine d'entreprises donatrice
on rachète en faute des lots auprès de
temps solidaire de peu de matériel
scolaire et on les propose un prix
vraiment de
presque donné mais pas tout à fait
malgré tout il est rentré un coup c'est
diarra geste de la part des familles à
cette année en particulier le coût des
matières premières augmentent et le coût
des fournitures scolaires je crois que
c'est 4% en moyenne mais c'est 25% sur
tout ce qui est papier donc pour les
personnes qui sont déjà en situation
financière difficile à voir en situation
de précarité en fait sa grève quand même
leur budget et donc c'est hyper
important de pouvoir
se procurer ces produits là dans une
association la vente des fournitures
scolaires à l'épicerie isa des mureaux
dure jusqu'au 7 septembre 2022